vamos ahora con información económica en
france 24 y estamos para eso con danger
hablando aunque nos va a contar lo más
importante hoy bienvenida a daniela
empezamos hablando de la organización
mundial del comercio porque el próximo
primero de marzo asumirá funciones la
nueva directora por primera vez en la
historia una mujer y además es aplicada
claro y liviana buenas noches miren la
nigeriana ngozi okonjo iweala como usted
lo dice es la primera mujer y además la
primera africana al frente de este
organismo ella llega en medio de un
creciente proteccionismo y de enormes
disputas comerciales entre países por
dirimir pero también jugará un papel
clave con relación al comercio de
medicamentos y vacunas en todo el mundo
que ya comenzó a generar asperezas otra
de sus tareas es reformar el proceso de
resolución de conflictos que muchos
consideran obsoleto por ejemplo eeuu y
la unión europea llevan casi dos décadas
enfrentados por los subsidios a sus
gigantes aeronáuticos y ahora tiene a la
casa blanca enfrentada con china también
es necesario adaptar las reglas
comerciales al comercio electrónico y a
la digitalización
justo cuando muchos países tienen los
ojos puestos sobre las grandes
tecnológicas
daniela para ella sí señora vamos a
hablar ahora de los datos de crecimiento
económico 2020 se conocieron justamente
este lunes y estos saludos siguen
demostrando como la pandemia del cob y
de 19 a hecho estragos en las economías
del mundo en 2020 hasta el momento sólo
china ha podido mostrar crecimiento pero
hay otros países como las naciones que
revelaron en sus datos pero tuvo la
contracción más fuerte fue del 11,2 12%
la peor en 30 años y con esto
interrumpió 22 años de crecimiento
sostenido colombia por su parte tuvo la
caída de su historia con 68 por ciento y
la tercera economía del mundo japón tuvo
su primer resultado negativo desde la
crisis de 2009 con un 4,8 por ciento
bueno daniela y china desplazó a estados
unidos como principal socio comercial de
la unión europea
liliana mientras que la relación entre
el bloque de 27 países y china atraviesa
por un buen momento
con eeuu parece deteriorarse cada vez
más las importaciones y exportaciones
desde hacía chinas subieron 5 6% y 2 2%
en el 2020 como podemos ver en el
gráfico pero por el contrario a eeuu
cayeron significativamente esto último
sucede en medio de las crecientes
tensiones comerciales que han tenido
bruselas y washington con la imposición
mutua de aranceles por la eterna disputa
de la que hablábamos antes por los
subsidios aeronáuticos con reino unido
también se está deteriorando la relación
comercial y amenaza con hacerlo todavía
más ahora que el break shit ya es una
realidad
daniela y en argelia quieren cambiar
petróleo por plátano cuéntanos la
historia la siguiente liviana este país
de áfrica del norte depende ampliamente
de sus hidrocarburos que representan
nueve de cada diez dólares que ingresan
por exportaciones pero no logró
desarrollar sus sectores no energéticos
antes de que cayeran los precios del
petróleo en su momento esos precios
superaron los 100 dólares por barril y
llega
a caer hasta precios negativos el año
pasado hoy en día son de alrededor de 60
dólares pues el gobierno anunció un plan
para reducir esta dependencia y de paso
bajar en un 60 por ciento de las
importaciones de alimentos por eso le
está apostando al banano concretamente
lanzó un programa con el que les presta
a los agricultores una hectárea de
tierra y les otorga préstamos con bajos
intereses para que lo cultiva en cerca
de la costa mediterránea el objetivo es
llegar a ser autosuficientes en unos
años escuchemos
nuestro objetivo es multiplicar las
superficies cultivadas y tener un
excedente primero cuando lo logremos
pensaremos en exportar y será un tipo de
banano que no existe en otros lugares
bueno pues que les vaya bien vamos a ver
ahora los indicadores de la jornada
daniela bueno y liliana wall street o no
pero hoy por ser día festivo pero si lo
hicieron las bolsas europeas que
cerraron con muy buenas ganancias
impulsadas por los avances en las
campañas de vacunación contra el kobe 19
en américa latina' argentina no pero
tampoco por ser día
por el resto de plazas bursátiles tuvo
movimientos mínimos y las dignas del día
daniela por favor 1.1 millones de euros
esta es la compensación que aceptó pagar
google en francia por prácticas
comerciales engañosas según la autoridad
francesa la empresa tenían su motor de
búsqueda una clasificación de hoteles
por estrellas según sus criterios y era
muy distinta a la clasificación oficial
es de daniela por la información
económica y ustedes gracias por estar
con nosotros continúen con más hembras
24 punto com
[Música]